bonjour à tous en deux mots je suis
avocat au barreau de paris
aujourd'hui vous avez de la chance deux
pour le prix d'un et je vais vous parler
d'un thème d'ailleurs assez proche de
celui qu'on a abordé ce matin je vais
pas parler de robots je vais pas parler
de machines mais de justice pénale
moi mon choix a été de défendre et c'est
un choix qu'on n'a pas toujours beaucoup
de facilité à comprendre et je vais un
petit peu essayé de mettre des mots sur
les questions que tout un chacun peut se
poser alors défendre les coupables et
vous allez voir que j'ai fait des
merveilleuses petites
alors d'abord défendre les coupables
c'est ça ne veut rien dire ça ne veut
rien dire pourquoi parce que vous le
savez vous vous le savez peut-être pas
soit on est déjà définitivement condamné
en france en droit soit on est déjà
définitivement condamné alors j'allais
dire on n'est plus défendu on n'a plus
besoin d'être défendue soit on n'est pas
encore définitivement condamné et dans
ce cas là on est innocent donc souvent
je je je prend à rebours votre question
parce que souvent on nous pose la
question comment vous faites pour
défendre des coupables
oui ben non d'abord quand une personne
vient nous nous contacter pour nous
confier la défense de st de ses intérêts
cette personne n'est pas coupable
en france c'est le jugement pénal
définitif qui va constituer la
culpabilité avant n'êtes pas coupable
vous êtes innocent c'est ce qu'on
appelle la présomption d'innocence c'est
très important parce que on se pose
toujours cette question là en voyant les
faits
les informations à la télévision ce type
il est coupable comment vous faites pour
défendre les coupables et ses excès
d'accord première chose oui mais vous
allez me dire d'accord la présomption
d'innocence bon mais en même temps
moralement il est forcément coupable il
ya forcément des gens qui viennent vous
voir et qui ont commis des choses
oui effectivement tous mes clients ne
sont pas innocents ou en tout cas ne
seront pas innocenté par une juridiction
certes mais moi je ne fais pas de morale
moi je fais du droit à un avocat fait du
droit et on n'est pas là pour on n'est
pas là pour être le le confident lamy le
père le prêtre je ne sais qui qui
pourrait avoir un jugement moral sur la
personne on est encore moins là pour
juger
on n'est pas le juge on est là où faire
une chose défendre
on est là pour porter la voix de
quelqu'un qui est poursuivi c'est ça en
fait le coeur de cette mission là on est
là pour porter la voix de quelqu'un pour
le représenter c'est le sens
c'est le sens même du mot avocat le sens
étymologique
il ya un double sens il ya d'abord le
sens de ces la personne l'avocat c'est
la personne qui est appelée au secours
par quelqu'un on est on appelle au
secours un défenseur c'est le sens c'est
le premier sens du mot avocat il ya
aussi le sens l'avocat est le porte-voix
celui qui va parler à la place 2 voilà
donc moi je vais parler à la place de
quelqu'un en prenant sa défense est
symboliquement je vais revêtir une robe
et cette robe ça signifie exactement
cela cette mission là c'est à dire quand
la revêtant je suis un autre que moi
même je ne suis plus moi même je ne suis
plus j'en ai loi de brunhoff je ne suis
plus tôt l'avocat je ne suis plus jeune
je ne je ne suis plus vieux je suis
celui que je représente et je vais
parler en son nom et on va pouvoir
s'adresser à lui par mois
comprenez donc en ces quelques mots
liminaire le coeur du métier d'avocat
que je pratique avocat en droit pénal la
défense pas le jugement
il y en a pour qui ce sera le métier pas
la poursuite pas les confidences par
défense alors ces quelques ces quelques
considérations et en étant rappelé je
souhaiterais parler avec vous de deux
choses sur cette question qui est assez
provocatrice
comment défendre un coupable il ya deux
deux manières de comprendre la question
comment défendre un coupable réserves
faites comme je voulais dit que un
coupable est encore présumé innocent
quand il va voir un avocat
la première la première façon de
comprendre cette question c'est comment
moralement comment osez vous comment
pouvez vous défendre un présumé coupable
on va dire comment vous pouvez le faire
moralement c'est ça parfois ça nous
dépasse
on n'arrive pas à comprendre et même
parfois on est hostile à l'avocat en
l'assimilant à
le client qu'il défend en l'assimilant
aux clients qui le défend alors et la
deuxième la deuxième le deuxième aspect
de cette question on le verra tout à
l'heure c'est plus juridiquement comment
on fait pour défendre quelqu'un qui est
poursuivi d'abord la question morale on
va parler de ça en premier parce que
c'est le plus important c'est souvent
comme ça que c'est souvent de là que
naissent les incompréhensions alors
d'abord comment on fait pour défendre
quelqu'un qui est poursuivi pour les
choses les pires pour les choses les
plus graves pour des crimes des crimes
violents des crimes sexuels pourquoi pas
des ti les crimes de terrorisme ça
arrive
comment comment on peut lire comment on
peut défendre ces types m comment vous
pouvez je vous comprends pas comment
vous faites et bien la réponse est les
basiques
elle est vraiment très simple elle est
très basique mais on l'oubli on oublie
trop souvent cette réponse là c'est la
dignité la dignité humaine c'est un
concept qui est galvaudé parce qu on
entend parfois parler là d'imiter les
uns l'utilisent dans un sens les autres
dans un sens opposé
mais la défense du de la personne
poursuivie même de la personne qui a
accusé des pires crimes
elle se justifie par ce simple mot
dignité humaine dignité humaine ça veut
dire on est des hommes on n'est pas des
chiens c'est tout simplement ça que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que même le pire
des criminels ou prétendus tels même
celui qui a commis les pires atrocités
c'est un homme et c'est pas un chien et
au titre du fait qu'il est un homme
on lui accorde des droits et on va le
traiter dignement
on va le traiter dignement ça veut dire
qu'il va avoir le droit à une défense
une défense de qualité et une défense
par un professionnel c'est-à-dire par
l'avocat il sera jugé dignement et cette
dignité là c'est très important de le
comprendre
elle ne dépend pas de ce qu'on a fait en
bien ou en mal dans notre vie elle ne
dépend pas non plus de qui on est si on
est un petit impuissant
un national un étranger elle ne dépend
pas de tout cela elle dépend du simple
fait qu'on est un homme quand les femmes
points et donc ça c'est ce qui me pousse
à agir en premier lieu la dignité
humaine pourquoi j'ai ça rend au fond de
moi même
voilà j'ai à coeur de la défense j'ai à
coeur la défense d'un homme parce qu'il
est homme quel que soit ce qu'il a
commis attention je défends pas l'acte
qu'il a commis un ni la cause qu'il a
servis je défends l'homme parce qu'il
est homme et qu'il a des droits que sa
qualité d'être humain lui accorde et le
terroriste je vais juste que je vais je
aller jusque là ce terroriste parce que
on entend malheureusement trop souvent
parler qui va jusqu'à baigner dénier la
dignité de ceux qu'il abat froidement
terroristes ou quelqu'un d'autre
celui qui qui conte a véritablement
envie de prendre immédiatement haut et
court est bien celui à celui là il faut
aussi alors je sais c'est des mots qui
peuvent choquer qui sont dures à
entendre mais il faut aussi même
peut-être surtout lui accorder la
dignité que lui nous conteste que lui
d'où nous dénie pourquoi parce que si je
lui dénient sa dignité d'être humain si
je leur tranche de l'humanité et c'est
ce qu'on est tenté de faire en temps en
les exécutant les excuses des exécutants
sans autre forme de procès et bien si je
lui dénier la dignité humaine que
lui-même le déni et à dénier à tous mes
enfants et mes proches qui sont morts eh
bien je me comporte comme lui et c'est
notre fierté
anne une civilisation française ici et à
beaucoup d'autres dans le monde
heureusement que de ne pas traiter les
individus qu'elle juge de la même façon
que ces individus ont traité les
citoyens d'accord on ne vaudrait pas
mieux
on ne vaudrait pas mieux en déniant sa
dignité à un être humain sous prétexte
qu'il a daigné la dignité de ceux qui
l'a tué
en est un homme et pas un chien première
première explication sur le plan moral
deuxièmement et bien c'est au nom de la
loi contenu qu'on sait au nom de la loi
qu'on agite bah oui parce que les droits
de tout âge les droits de toutes
personnes poursuivies sont prévues par
des textes un avocat tout comme un juge
comme un policier obéit à des règles qui
sont des règles de procédure pénale
procédure civilement là je parle du
droit pénal et ces règles là elles sont
discutées voter établi à prouver par nos
représentants nationaux et c'est pas une
facilité que de dire ça on se cache pas
derrière c'est le principe même de notre
démocratie
si vous n'êtes pas content avec le fait
que quelqu'un est un avocat même un
terroriste eh bien il faut changer la
loi
d'accord donc c'est c'est l'avocat
n'invente rien de son chapeau ne sort
rien de son chapeau qui ne soit prévue
par des lois votées par nos
représentants au terme d'un processus
démocratique qui bon gré mal gré
fonctionne il est toujours critiquable
ce processus démocratique mais bon gré
mal gré ça fonctionne troisième et
dernière raison que j'ai envie de
partager avec vous sur le plan moral
l'état de droit là je vais prendre un
tout petit peu de hauteur et si tu es
mon action non pas seulement dans la
défense d'un individu qui vient me voir
mais je vais prendre un peu de hauteur
en envoyant mon action à moi avocat en
droit pénal comme son prétention mais
comme une contribution au maintien de ce
qu'on appelle l'état de droit ça veut
dire quoi l'état de droit basiquement un
très simplement ça veut dire une société
dans laquelle les droits de chacun sont
respectées dans laquelle l'exercice du
pouvoir et l'exercice de la violence par
les autorités est encadrée par les
règles et voilà une société dans
laquelle l'arbitraire je dirais pas n'a
pas de place mais en tous les cas n'est
pas censé avoir de place c'est ça l'état
de droit en inde et en défendant une
personne que tout accable peut-être qui
est véritablement l'auteur du crime en
la défendant du mieux que je peux en
utilisant tous ses droits
en le faisant avec conviction en réalité
qu'est ce que je
qu'est ce que je fais également eh bien
je fais en sorte que nos autorités de
justice ne condamne pas sans preuves
suffisantes quelqu'un et demain c'est
vous c'est vous c'est vous c'est moi
placé dans une situation et oyonnax où
vous seriez poursuivi pour pour une
mauvaise raison pour 200 motif et bien
c'est vous qui auraient bénéficié du
fait que tous les avocats auront défendu
les personnes criminels avant avant vous
comprenez c'est à dire qu'en agissant
pour la défense d'un individu en réalité
jeu permet au système au système de
protéger le coupable comme l'innocent
demain et vous savez les erreurs
judiciaires
ça peut arriver les gérons les erreurs
police police hier encore plus d'erreurs
policières c'est c'est une erreur de
départ les policiers arrivent ils
entrent dans une enquête c'est très
difficile pour eux ils font un métier
sous pression ils arrivent ils
interviennent le soir à 3 heures du
matin il fait nuit à une victime qui dit
c'est lui c'est lui c'est lui
ils font pas tellement dans le détail
ils sont pas là pour ça au départ c'est
un métier dur mais ils peuvent avoir
tendance à se tromper au départ s'il
n'ya pas l'avocat qui intervient pour
critiquer l'action de la police en
disant non cette personne cette personne
cette personne il n'y a pas de preuve
contre elle il n'y a pas de preuve
contre elle
peut-être peut-être bien que cette
personne était totalement innocente et
que
et que les juges auront pris l'habitude
ont pris l'habitude et bien de de
respecter très scrupuleusement très
scrupuleusement les droits de la défense
de toute personne poursuivie donc
l'action de l'avocat elle se situe aussi
aussi sur un plan collectif de défense
de l'état de droit
ce sont les trois les trois raisons qui
sur un plan moral me pousse à défendre
comment osez vous défendre ça c'était le
premier aspect comment pouvez vous
défendre quelqu'un que tout accable même
un terroriste est horrible et on pourra
en reparler si les paroles si mes propos
sont difficiles mais même un terroriste
a le droit à une défense de qualité et
je vais même aller jusqu'à dire même si
c'est difficile à entendre et on pourra
reparler si vous voulez un terroriste
qui n'a pas les moyens vous savez on a
entendu parler de cette polémique
un terroriste qui n'aurait pas les
moyens de se défendre parce qu'il ya
tout simplement pas d'argent il a le
droit de bénéficier comme tous les
autres citoyens comme tous les autres
toutes les autres personnes poursuivies
d'un avocat aux besoins gratuitement par
le biais des commissions d'office
eh bien nous notre société prévoit parce
qu'elle considère que les droits de la
défense sont si importants prévoit
d'attribuer un avocat gratuitement même
un terroriste et ça c'est dur mais c'est
une fierté de notre civilisation qui a
mûri longuement pour accorder autant de
droits de la défense
du point de vue juridique et ça sera ma
deuxième ça sera ma deuxième nom
deuxième axe d'entrée dans cette
question comment défendre un coupable
maintenant mais c'est comment on fait
pour défendre et ça aussi c'est super
intéressant comment on fait pour
défendre un coupable
il reconnaît les faits reconnaît pas les
faits s'il vous dit que il est innocent
alors que s'il dit qu'il est innocent
juge alors que vous avez dit dans votre
oreille mais tu mettes je suis coupable
mais surtout dit que je suis innocent
comment vous faites comment vous faites
alors d'abord la première chose à faire
quand on est avocat
c'est d'abord de vérifier que les droits
de la personne poursuivie ont bien été
respectées
ah oui alors là ça peut souvent beaucoup
de questions on ne comprend pas même
parfois on s'indigne parce que un avocat
va examiner en premier lieu la procédure
la forme est parfois va invoquer ce
qu'on appelle vous savez bien un vice de
forme ou un vice de procédure alors on
comprend pas qu'est ce que c'est que
cette histoire il ya quelqu'un qui
peut-être un grand criminel et qui va
peut-être être relâchés parce qu'on aura
une petite virgule qui aura été mise à
un mauvais endroit
un petit mot de trop un délai pas
respecté qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire
alors là sans faire d'histoires sans
reprendre trop loin dans les siècles
il faut il faut bien aussi avoir une il
faut bien avoir en tête une chose
importante c'est que en france
l'exercice de la violence légitime
l'exercice de la violence légitime a été
confisqué au profit de l'état si vous
êtes importunée par un camarade demain
vous ne pouvez pas le provoquer en duel
ou prendre son chien par les tripes
devant l'entrée de sa maison
comment vous faites même si vous en avez
très envie
vous devez aller déposer plainte et seul
l'état les autorités de police et de
justice auront le pouvoir légitimement
et bien d' exercer là violence contre
contre vous c'est à dire le cas échéant
de vous arrêter vous placé en garde à
vue de la garde à vue vous placer en
détention provisoire avant le procès on
en a parlé tout à l'heure et après le
procès de vous pas le placer en prison
c'est une violence et les policiers
interviennent dans la rue avec un
pistolet à la ceinture et peuvent
peuvent l'utiliser
cette violence la boîte être strictement
encadrer strictement encadrée parce que
si elle n'est pas strictement encadrée
alors c'est le far west c'est le shérif
qui qui sort son pistolet pour un oui ou
pour un non et où dès qu'il a
l'impression que quoi qu'il se passe
quelque chose de louche donc l'exercice
de la violence légitime doit être
strictement encadré c'est pour notre
bien tous c'est pour notre sécurité à
tous c'est pour notre liberté
penseur du droit vos niering disait que
la forme ou la procédure est la soeur
jumelle de la liberté oui parce qu'en
fait la procédure
elle permet de combattre l'arbitraire
d'accord elle et les excès de violence
et donc je vous donne un petit exemple
si vous êtes placé demain en garde à vue
parce que vous avez trop bu et vous avez
conduit vous êtes placé en garde à vue
on vous prive de votre liberté votre
liberté c'est quand même ce qu'il ya de
plus essentiel votre liberté
individuelle d'aller et venir c'est ce
qu'il ya de plus essentiel
on est d'accord c'est une atteinte grave
à vos droits et bien à ce moment là le
policier il a le droit de le faire mais
il doit prévenir immédiatement un
magistrat qu'on appelle le procureur de
la république pour lui dire monsieur le
procureur qui est un magistrat chargé
justement de la protection des libertés
eh bien j'ai placer quelqu'un en garde à
vue je les priver de sa liberté
s'il ne le faisait pas si personne ne
contrôle ce policier alors c'est
l'arbitraire et donc s'il ne le fait pas
et que l'avocat le voit il dit aux juges
monsieur le juge cet individu a été
placé en garde à vue alors même et sans
être sans que pardon sans que le
policier n'en informe immédiatement le
procureur de la république c'est une
atteinte grave à sa liberté individuelle
qu'on ne peut pas tolérer dans notre
site dans notre société
quand bien même il serait coupable peu
importe vous ne pouvez pas monsieur le
juge a accepté que la police se comporte
de cette manière là sinon c'est
l'arbitraire et c'est les excès c'est
l'autoritarisme
donc monsieur le juge je vous demande de
rendre nulle
le procès verbal d'interpellation la
procédure et le cas échéant
effectivement cette nullité peut
entraîner jusqu'à l'arrêt des poursuites
alors bon c'est je schématise mais c'est
ça que ça veut dire
la procédure elle est là pour nous elle
est là pour nous pour pour nos libertés
alors ça c'est la première chose à faire
quand on est avocat voilà comment on
défend quelqu'un kaki qu'il quel qu'il
soit
la deuxième chose c'est alors la
question de la vérité
on pense souvent que on est attaché à la
vérité on nous dit bon mètre alors donc
que s'il reconnaît les faits s'il
reconnaissait pas les pneus alors que
cela soit clair je vais peut-être un
petit peu aussi enlever certaines des
îles de certaines illusions
il n'existe pas en matière judiciaire de
vérité avec un grand v
une sorte de vérité objective une vérité
des faits une vérité peut-être
transcendantale sur laquelle tout le
monde devrait être d'accord parce que
c'est la vérité point c'est la vérité
des faits objectifs d'historique
quelques couacs wacom pourquoi qu'on le
donne comme non en matière judiciaire il
n'existe que des versions il ya la
version d'intel la version d'intel
si je vous demande à vous monsieur de
raconter aujourd'hui la conférence tedx
voulez vous allez la raconter de votre
point de vue intervenant il était pas
mal
vous avez mal dormi vous avez un peu
vous avez mal dormi cette nuit vous avez
trouvé ça conflent vous avez joué sur
votre portable et vous et vous madame
par contre vous avez trouvé ça super et
vous avez dit rester un super
intervenants et puis il était il était
très très beau dans son costume bleu
marine mais non ils étaient ils étaient
loin son costume on aura tous vous êtes
une centaine on aura tous une version
différente en justice c'est pareil à un
juge qui vient 10 rebonds alors que
qu'est ce qui s'est passé vous allez
raconter votre manière de votre manière
dont vous êtes tous des témoins du crime
vous êtes tous raconté d'une manière un
peu différente et puis surtout l'accusé
il va avoir une manière différente de
raconter son ce qu'on lui reproche de la
victime évidemment donc en fait la
vérité c'est un concept vaporeux duquel
il faut se méfier quand on est avocat on
il faut il faut pas tellement il faut
pas il faut la mettre de côté
il vous dit qu'il est coupable il nous
dit qu'il est innocent
qu'est ce qu'on regarde à quoi nous
attaquent à quoi devons-nous nous
attacher un aux éléments matériels voilà
ce qui nous dit alors on écoute bien sûr
et puis parfois c'est très important
d'écouter ce que nous dit notre client
je dis pas que ils mettent tous mais ils
mentent pour beaucoup et tout le monde
non cantons surtout quand on nous
reproche quelque chose donc ce qu'on dit
et puis parfois on dit qu'on est
innocent et c'est faux et parfois on dit
qu'on est ico ou qu'on est coupable mais
c'est aussi faux parce que on se laisse
accusés
parce que on a peur de balancer le vrai
nom etc
on a peur des représailles et quand on
sera dehors on se fera
zigouiller notre chien bon et bien on
peut aussi mentir ou on peut aussi ne
pas dire la vérité en se laissant accusé
en disant qu'on est coupable donc la
vérité voilà on l'est on les cartes ont
les cartes des débats la vérité
judiciaire s'il y en a une ça sera ce la
thèse
ça sera la thèse qui aura été le plus
suffisamment étayé la plus le plus
suffisamment prouvé la voilà il va y
avoir une forme de vérité judiciaire un
compromis entre différentes thèses qui
s'affrontent on prendra celle le juge
prendra celle qui est la plus
convaincante et le juge du dessus la
cour d'appel si elle n'est pas d'accord
avec le juge du dessous elle va casser
la décision du premier juge
donc ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que
le premier juge concrètement il aura
commis une erreur judiciaire entre
guillemets pas de vérité donc donc les
éléments matériels et j'en viens mon
dernier point
quelles sont les preuves voilà la vraie
question quelles sont les preuves
vous me dites que vous êtes innocent
peut-être que vous êtes coupable ok
voyons ce qu'il ya dedans aujourd'hui
voyons ce qu'il ya dans le dossier
aujourd'hui la police et la justice à sa
disposition
comme dirait un nombre absolument
incalculable de moyens techniques
scientifiques en tous genres pour
prouver c'est à la justice de faire la
preuve de votre culpabilité est elle à
sa disposition que je voulais dire des
moyens colossaux
c'est à elle de faire votre la preuve de
sa culpabilité si elle ne le fait pas
vous êtes vous êtes vous avez vous avez
rien compris
si la justice ne prouve pas que vous
êtes coupable vous êtes
ah oui bon sang innocent et donc et donc
c'est ça qu'on doit regarder nous autres
avocats on doit regarder si dans le
dossier il ya suffisamment de preuves de
votre culpabilité sinon vous êtes
innocent et donc je regarde dans le
dossier monsieur mon client
cher monsieur bon vous me dites que vous
êtes innocent que vous êtes innocent bon
d'accord je vous entends par contre dans
le dossier il ya ça ça et ça et ça
contre vous ça va être un peu dur là
parce qu'il ya quand même une centaine
de témoins qui vous ont vu un instant tu
es l'intervenant parce que vous trouviez
qu'il était très mauvais donc ça va être
ça va être un peu dur de ça va être un
peu dur de contester alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait là on va dans le mur si alors
qu alors qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on va peut-être évoluer on va
peut-être trouvé une explication mais en
tous les cas dire que vous êtes innocent
alors que tout le monde vous a vu ça va
être difficile on a un rôle de conseil
voilà et si vous le faites monsieur
c'est vous qui allez prendre la décision
c'est lui qui va faire son choix
si vous le faites si vous continuez de
dire que vous êtes innocent alors qu'il
ya une centaine de personnes qui vous a
vu et bien on va dans le mur et vous
risquez ça pour risquer sa vie pour
époux risque et ça vous voulez ok mais
je vous aurais je vous aurais prévenu
rôle de conseil mais aussi rôle de
porte-voix parce que in fine et c'est le
client qui décide c'est pas moi qui veux
dire à sa place qu'il est innocent ou
coupable s'il veut dire qu'il est
innocent malgré santé - je l'aurais
averti et puis il prendra une prendra un
carton
donc ça c'est ça et si et si deuxième
cas de figure s'il n'y a pas de preuves
suffisantes dans le dossier qui me
disent qu'il est coupable ou qu'ils me
disent qu'il n'est pas coupable
s'il n'y a pas de preuves suffisantes
mon rôle à moi c'est de dire aux juges
monsieur le juge on aimerait bien le
condamner on serait tenté en plus de ça
il a un casier long comme le bras et
puis toute la justice prédictive
laisserait penser que c'est
effectivement lui le coupable est il là
il a eu des échecs sentimentaux il a
plein de il a plein de casier il a un
casier long comme le bras
un délit de fuite en prime
qui lui est reproché on a vu que ça
c'était une cause aggravante au niveau
de la probabilité
oui mais dans le dossier il n'y a pas
assez de preuves
ce que dit la victime c'est pas
suffisant pour condamner c'est pas
suffisant pour condamner et
malheureusement j'ai envie de dire pour
certaines victimes réelles
heureusement pour notre société on ne
condamne pas seulement sur la plainte
d'une victime qui ne seraient
corroborées par aucun autre élément
matériel
donc mon rôle à moi deux avocats c'est
de dire que vous le croyez innocent ou
coupable qu'il ait la tête de l'emploi
ou non vous pouvez libérer et de ce
point de vue là j'aimerais finir en vous
disant vous dit
en vous disant ceci de ce point de vue
là vous connaissez sûrement l'adage il
vaut mieux prendre le risque de relâcher
un coupable
plutôt que de condamner un innocent vaut
mieux relâché un coupable
plutôt que de prendre le risque de
condamner un innocent moi je vais aller
plus loin je vais vous dire il vaut
mieux relâché un coupable faute
alors on va dire un coupable je n'aime
pas cette expression faute un couple
quelqu'un qui aurait vraiment commis les
faits il vaut mieux relâché un coupables
faute de preuves suffisantes que de
condamner un coupable sans preuves
suffisantes
ça peut choquer sur le plan de la
justice individuelle comment mais
relâché un coupable moi j'ai aucun
plaisir à faire relâcher des personnes
qui ont effectivement pu commettre telle
ou telle infraction ça ne me procure
strictement aucun plaisir je situe pas
là mon action pas pour lui faire plaisir
je situe encore une fois mon action dans
le cadre de ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure la digne de la défense de la
dignité des droits voté par l'assemblée
et de l'état de droit mais
sur un plan collectif si jamais vous
condamner quelqu'un peut être
véritablement coupable sans preuves
suffisantes
alors demain vous condamnerez quelqu'un
qui est pas du bon innocent parce qu'on
aura pris l'habitude de condamner sans
preuves suffisantes
je remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]